all right guys
bang bang zak is back and he's got some
big news today what's going on man
you only want to talk to me when we
raise money i don't know what the
deal it's like we have some good
financing news and all of a sudden you
let me come on the show again
i'm begging you to come on the show but
zack is uh is too busy these days
now um all right let's just get the news
right out of the way for those who don't
know
zack is uh the founder and ceo of uh
block fi
and uh you raise some money so maybe
just start with the news and then we'll
do
a do an overview of block five yeah so
uh we
are announcing i don't know when we're
gonna publish this but you know thursday
august 20th that we closed a series c
round of funding for the company
uh 50 million dollar uh all equity
investment rounds
uh led by yours truly anthony pompliano
at morgan creek uh pomp's going to be
joining our board
uh which is uh which is really exciting
he's been you know
instrumental in uh helping us get to
where we are today so maybe i'll turn
this question around on you in a second
pop and say well why'd you why'd you
leave this investment around
um but we had some really awesome
participants in the rounds some of our
existing investors
like vallar who led the series a in
series b
folks like winklevoss capital fidelity
some of our other
you know institutional firms that have
invested uh in subsequent rounds in the
company
um and we added some new folks as well
so we're not able to say their names but
we actually had direct investments from
two university endowments one ivy league
one non-ivy league
uh scb10x which is the
largest uh bank in thailand uh it's
their venture arm
um and uh an nba player matthew
dellavedova aka delhi he actually uh did
an interview with coindesk so i'm
curious
to see if they uh quote him and uh i'm
really excited about maybe doing some
more stuff in the in the sports world
um but yeah you know proceeds are going
towards the same stuff that they always
go to building more products growing the
team
and trying to add more value for our
clients
and putting our capital position
in a increasingly stronger and stronger
place
which is really important for a company
that's in the type of business uh
that we're in so um you know
we've actually raised equity capital
every six months since we started the
company three years ago
which is uh an insane pace and it's
reflective of like
how quickly we've been able to grow um
and you know it kind of it used to be
like oh my gosh
we raised the money thank goodness like
we did it uh okay let's take a little
breather this one felt very
um you know kind of opportunistic and
operational it's like boom all right
let's knock it out
get the term sheets pick the one we're
going with of course we're gonna go with
pomp's term sheet
uh pic pick the one we're going with
close it and like just keep moving so so
we're excited
awesome so i i realized that uh there
might be
one or two people who are listening who
actually don't know what block fight
does maybe give us a quick
overview of what block fight does and
then we'll get back to the uh the
funding news
yeah sure so um you know the original
idea for block five
was uh to build debt and credit markets
for the crypto space
so i was working in fintech specifically
in the online lending sector
i was personally investing in bitcoin i
tried to get a
loan from a bank to buy an investment
property in texas
love the salt lake cap by the way a
shout out to awesome austin bbq
and this is back in like early 2017.
price my bitcoin had gone up a lot and
so i included it on the financial
statement that i submitted to the bank
and uh you know the bank freaked out and
they're like bitcoin isn't worth
anything
we're worried that you're a terrorist or
whatever and i was like you know
all of the stuff that uh has existed in
the
lending world for fintech is also going
to need to exist
in the cryptocurrency ecosystem this is
going to be a massive asset class
banks are going to be slow to touch it
and that creates an opportunity
uh you know to build a business around
around that idea
and so that was the original idea 2017
we started
fast forward to today we're really a
uh financial services company that's
focused on building products
for uh cryptocurrency investors so you
can download the block fight app
and earn interest on your bitcoin uh six
percent interest on your bitcoin
eight point six percent interest on uh
you know cash equivalents
uh stable coins uh we also support ether
and litecoin
uh you can trade so you can wire money
into your block fight count
earn 8.6 on it until you decide to buy
bitcoin you can buy bitcoin in the app
and then you're instantly earning
interest on the bitcoin instead of the
cash
and you can also get a loan secured by
the value of your cryptocurrency
portfolio
uh if you you know want some liquidity
without having to sell it
so those are the three products that we
have today um it's available on the web
and in the mobile app and
you know we're launching uh more stuff
in the future but um that's what we do
175 people at the company now which is
crazy absolutely nuts so um
these three products i think one of the
key pieces um
for what gets me excited is most
businesses
in crypto start out as these brokerage
businesses right so the example that
i've used
with with you obviously uh for other
people to understand is
um robin hood for example in the uh
in the traditional markets starts out
brokerage first and then tries to from a
growth perspective go geographic
expansion
you know step one step two is add other
products to kind of their product suite
um it's pretty hard for a brokerage
business to add
other types of products if they're not
other brokerage products right so you
can add derivatives and futures and
things like that but
if you want to get into credit cards
debit cards you know deposit type
accounts cash accounts all that kind of
stuff is
pretty difficult if you compare that to
like a square
square starts out with deposits and
payments they then end up adding crypto
they add cards they add
you know um payment uh product they've
added
fractional shares or kind of their own
brokerage business like deposits and
payments seem to be
kind of a stronger place to start if
your goal is to have a very robust
product suite and i think that in crypto
you guys have been kind of the leader or
one of the
the companies that realized this early
and you start out with
deposits payments and now i've continued
to add these services maybe talk a
little bit about how you guys think
about
kind of the deposit being so important
to the business model
and then how you think about adding you
know other products to the suite over
time
sure well your you know your ability to
monetize and create revenue on a
financial
services platform is generally a
derivative of
balances on the platform so if you
you know if you have more customers who
are holding more assets on your platform
um then you have a better chance of
being able to you know make money
uh off of those assets so it's kind of
uh it's always a game about
you know getting balances and then
figuring out ways to
uh you know monetize those balances
which intersects
with enabling your customers to do more
things with them or
you know launching more products so
um you know that's the way we've always
we've always thought about it one of the
other reasons why this is important
is uh financial services is a is a
you know kind of hyper competitive um
industry
and i think crypto is even more
competitive than traditional financial
services because you're competing on a
global scale
you know with blockchain technology
and everyone at least everyone that's in
the industry already sees the
opportunity so there's a lot of you know
investment and excitement and smart
people working in the space
and so you know we believed uh from
really early on that a core part of our
strategy has to be
uh constantly releasing new products
that add value for our clients
so that you know one you can add
monetization into the platform from
these balances that you know should be
growing
but two you can create stickiness with
folks so we've kind of
thought about the end goal for us in
terms of the client relationship that we
want to have
as being the equivalent to you know
when someone gets a mailer and this
probably happens to you
i know it happens to me all the time
from a bank and they're like hey we'll
give you 200
to open up a new checking account and
you throw it away
not because 200 you know wouldn't be
nice to have but because
you do all your stuff with uh with a
certain bank you kind of got your setup
figured out in terms of you know where
your checking and savings account are
where your credit cards are where your
mortgage is and you don't want to go
through the you know
work and pain in the butt of uh of
switching all that stuff just for 200
so that's the type of relationship we
want to have with our clients and the
way you do that
is create a compelling product suite so
that someone can you know
not only earn interest on their bitcoin
but they can also
get a loan against their portfolio if
they ever need to they can buy and sell
it if they ever need to
um we're really excited about uh our
first product that we're launching
in the payment space which is going to
be a bitcoin rewards credit card so you
can
spend money every day on a credit card
and earn bitcoin as rewards for it and
that's just going to flow into your
interest account immediately when you
get the rewards
um and if someone
engages with all those products and then
they get a you know
letter in the mail from another company
saying hey we'll give you
a hundred dollars worth of bitcoin to
come try and do some of those same
things that you're doing with block fi
over here we want them to just throw it
away it's not worth it i'm happy with
block five
they've given me you know great client
service
i trust the team and the product i'm
familiar with how it works it's really
easy to use
um and so uh you know that's that's the
end goal for us
yeah and one of the things that that has
been really interesting uh
for me to see is this default
digital currency world that you've
created so when somebody
brings money into the system it doesn't
sit in cash ever
right it sits in a stable coin and so
kind of explain
how that works and why that's important
um because
because i do think that it also changes
the mindset of a user right like you are
in this digital ecosystem
um let's talk a little bit about that
yeah so i mean uh first off just in case
anybody doesn't understand a stable coin
um you know imagine if uh well
you know jim and i coinbase couple other
folks have done this let's use gemiini
for this example folks send them money
they hold it in a bank account
and they they you know get that audited
and the cash just sits in a bank
somewhere
but then they release one-to-one um
digital
versions of those dollars in a bank
account for them it's called
gusd the gemini dollar and so
when you fund a block fight account from
your bank which you can do via a wire
transfer
it doesn't sit as dollars at block by it
sits as gusd
but that's basically interchangeable
with dollars you can you know
wire it back out to your bank account um
but the reason we represent it that way
is that uh it enables us
to uh kind of
do some of the things that we want to do
without falling squarely into
uh traditional types of regulatory boxes
um and you get all the benefits
of having it as cryptocurrency which are
you know you can transfer it on
blockchain payment rails
uh you're you know taking part in this
in this new ecosystem
and it is a little bit different than
just holding a dollar in a bank account
but
uh in ways that are largely positive
yeah um let's talk about how things are
going so
uh people are going to read in the news
uh 50 million dollar
series c uh obviously things must be
going well
but what metrics can you share kind of
publicly as to how things are going with
the business
yeah sure so um you know to touch on a
couple of uh
you know high level stats uh we'll use
the end of last year as a benchmark so
like you know december
uh december 2019 we made less than a
million dollars
uh in our you know in that month in
terms of top line revenue
uh today that number is is just under 10
million uh for the month of july
um we had about 200 million dollars in
assets uh
you know aggregate asset value on the
platform today it's over
1.5 billion uh our team was
less than 100 people i think around like
80 between 80 and 90 when we ended the
year today it's it's over 175
and we didn't have a mobile app we
didn't have the ability for
folks to send us money uh directly from
their bank account
um and uh our trading feature
launched uh like december 15th so at the
beginning of the month you you couldn't
buy and sell bitcoin
by the end of december 2019 you could
buy and sell bitcoin but now we're
starting to see
uh you know real volumes uh flowing
through
uh that that product which is which is
awesome
um so yeah it's uh you know it's been
um really incredible growth including
i think pretty notably through uh
the coronavirus you know situation that
we're in and the volatility that
uh the crypto market uh experience uh
in march when you know we were kind of
digesting that news
and we've maintained from a risk
management perspective
our perfect performance uh all along the
way
so um you know we're doing a lot of
lending activities we've
grown those in in tandem with uh the
growth in our asset base and
uh we've continued to have perfect
performance never lost a penny
across any of the lending that we do
yeah so
for those that missed that uh in seven
eight months you've almost 10xed revenue
you've increased assets by six or seven
x
uh all while keeping that perfect track
record on the lending side
talk a little bit about why is that so
important and how do financial service
businesses think about
kind of no loss of capital when it comes
to those lending practices
um sure so uh i mean it's
um it's important for a ton of reasons
maybe the most important thing yeah i
mean look uh
yeah as with any other type of you know
investment or you know allocation of
capital
uh it's always better not to not lose
any than it is to uh to lose some
so um one of the one of the conscious
decisions that we made
in terms of uh what types of lending we
wanted to do
at blockfi uh this is going very early
on you know i came out of the online
lending world where a lot of what
happened
peer-to-peer online lending world a lot
of what went on there was
unsecured consumer loans and
that's a you can build a really big and
successful business there but you're
dealing with defaults where you lose
principle
and it's really hard to predict um
because there's a lot of you know
variables uh
related to the macroeconomic cycle or
where someone lives or how they're doing
professionally
what your performance is going to be on
that loan book
contrast that to the type of lending
that blockfi does which is
primarily lending that is collateralized
with liquid assets
so if someone's borrowing dollars
against their crypto portfolio they're
doing that at a maximum
you know 50 initial loan to value ratio
so with 10 000 worth of bitcoin you can
borrow five thousand dollars
um and then on the institutional lending
that we do
similar concept but slightly tighter
ratios
and this type of lending which is most
analogous to
uh securities lending in the traditional
financial world
is one of the least risky types of
lending out there
so our chief risk officer rene van
kesterin who
was a managing director at bammel before
becoming our chief risk officer
he oversaw all of this lending within
the prime brokerage arm of merrill lynch
and then
and then bank of america merrill lynch
and
never lost a penny while he was doing it
there including through
the you know 2008 uh financial crisis
so um i like that type of lending better
than stuff where you have defaults it
seems like
uh you know when you've got an asset
class like crypto which is still
so nascent and volatile when uh compared
to traditional assets um
you know being on the conservative end
of the risk spectrum in terms of the
types of lending that you're doing makes
a lot of sense and that's kind of uh you
know
how we operate yeah and speaking of uh
the lending
talk a little bit the number one
question i get from people who
uh are unfamiliar either with uh this
type of business or
uh are looking at crypto uh for the
first time is they see
you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy on an interest bearing
account
um kind of give people the 60 seconds on
how exactly you guys are able to pay
that um and why that product is so
compelling to folks
yeah sure so you know we're able to pay
it because that's what we're
uh we're charging folks similar rates
when we lend dollars
uh to them in the form of stable coins
the reason that
people who borrow those dollars from us
are willing to pay those higher rates is
because
the cryptocurrency sector doesn't have
access to the same types of low-cost
financing
that traditional sectors do because
banks aren't here
you know a lot of the largest kind of
debt and credit focused asset management
firms aren't here yet
and as a result the cost of capital is
higher in
in crypto um you know an analogy there
would be
uh like the cannabis industry uh for
example where
you know it's newer not as many banks
are active
maybe some folks are still figuring out
how they feel about it from a regulatory
and compliance perspective and as a
result if you have you know a cannabis
business and you want to
get a loan um you have to pay much
higher rates than
if you're trying to get a loan as a uh
you know more traditional business like
a ups store or
a pizza restaurant or something and the
same thing is true for crypto and that's
why the rates are where they are and
why is it compelling i mean it's uh it's
compelling because i don't know a single
traditional like savings account
or you know product from a bank where
you're getting even over one percent
these days i mean rates are
turning downwards the fed has uh you
know said that they intend to keep it
that way at least through 2023 i think
um so you know you can't get yield
anywhere it's crazy
to folks our age to think that you know
there was a point in time where you
could earn eight percent in a savings
account
like you know those those days are gone
and so
being able to do it with a company like
block five because it's kind of
doing similar types of activities but
within the cryptocurrency sector is
really awesome and you can just you know
do the math
however much money you have in an
account earning point eight percent at
uh marcus with goldman sachs or an
allies high yield savings account
multiply it by 10 like that's how much
you'll earn if it's
if it's in an account with block buy
absolutely
um how has the macro environment right
so kind of what's crazy to me
is um we obviously are seeing you know
incredible growth at blockfy at the
exact same time
that uh we're seeing the pandemic and
kind of a recession right so you've got
a pandemic that's got this public health
crisis
element to it and then you've got you
know 50 plus million americans who lost
their jobs
all those small businesses that are
coming under pressure uh through the
government mandated shutdown all that
kind of stuff
uh would you agree or disagree with
that has actually been a tailwind in the
sense of people are looking for
alternatives from that legacy system
or do you not see any kind of connection
there so far
it's definitely been a tailwind there's
the tailwind of
people doing more things digitally
out of necessity right uh because of the
health situation so
online brokerages uh in the financial
world
um you know online services and in
general have done really well and so
we're you know catching a little bit of
that
uh trend um the other thing
is that uh in a time where you've got
central bank uh responses to
this crisis being you know as expected
to
increase the money supply and you have
people sitting at home with a bit more
spare time than they used to have
because they're not flying
not socializing the same way they used
to reading about what this means
things like you know gold in the past
have done really well i think bitcoin is
is part of that
story now and as a result the
cryptocurrency asset class is part of
that story
so more people are getting interested in
it
um we catch a little bit of uh you know
that trend
and then lastly we're part of a story
within the crypto sector of
more products and services being built
specifically around this asset class
and more kind of traditional financial
services
companies and and uh you know functions
uh being available to crypto investors
um so all of those things together are
kind of you know combined to
um have made you know the last five
months or whatever it is since uh
since all this all this stuff started
the best five months we've ever had is
business
yeah that's awesome uh it's a lot of
money on the balance sheet now what are
you guys gonna do with it
um we're just gonna you know we're just
gonna keep going we're launching the
bitcoin rewards credit card
we're really excited about that we think
it's gonna be a fun product for people
who
already understand and you know own some
bitcoin but also a great product for
uh people who are kind of crypto curious
or have always wanted some but they just
you know haven't really taken the plunge
because
everybody's familiar with you know
earning reward points on a credit card
super low risk way to get some exposure
we've been expanding internationally so
you know we have
uh folks on the ground now in london and
singapore
uh so we'll be growing those teams and
growing our efforts in
in markets outside the u.s um
and uh other than that it's you know
just uh
just kind of steady execution the same
way we've been doing
uh you know over the last uh couple of
years
absolutely uh obviously you guys are
continuing to
grow the product which means you have to
grow people talk a little bit about what
some of the roles are that you're
looking for
everything man um if you have you know i
mean
if you have uh you know skills whether
it's uh
engineering or marketing or
uh you know institutional
uh type trading and risk management
stuff operations finance i mean
uh if you go to um you know if you type
in like block five jobs in google it'll
take you to our jobs page and
i don't know how many are posted right
now but uh we're expecting to be around
250 people by the end of this year
um so uh we're definitely hiring and i
think
you know one of the things i'm most
proud of is
the quality of the team that we've built
and i think even in a world where we're
not going into the office every day
uh for the foreseeable future
we've done a good job of uh maintaining
this
you know culture that we have as a
company of
having people who enjoy what they're
doing who are super capable who
uh you know are a pleasure to work with
and uh we're just doing it through zoom
now instead of uh
instead of in the office love that um
two things that i know people if we
don't talk about will uh will tweet at
us and we'll be doing customer service
on twitter
first is uh give us an update on the
bitcoins rewards credit card
what does that timeline look like and
kind of any updates there
yeah so um we hit uh you know we hit we
hit
a bit of a uh delay with covid because
in order to launch the bitcoin rewards
credit card we have to have
a card network partner a bank partner
and a program management partner
um i won't say which ones but some of
that partnership
set kind of you know struggle to
transition as quickly from a world where
you're in the office to a world where
you're fully remote
you can probably guess which one but um
it's still coming out
teams working on it we're really excited
about it i think we'll have the first
cards in market
uh this year um those first cards are
probably going to go to
uh you know folks uh that work at
blockfy and
maybe you know investors and influencers
like pomp so you'll probably see
pomp recording videos paying for things
with his bitcoin rewards credit card
before uh
for the holiday season and then we'll
have a broader more public roll out
early next year you'll be able to get on
the waiting list this year we'll be
releasing details
starting in a month or two about how
it's going to work who the partners are
what the rates are
uh what you have to do to get the card
um what it looks like all that good
stuff so
uh the wheels are in motion we're really
excited man i mean i get mad every day
you know like i'm
buying something with my delta amex or
my my chase sapphire card or whatever
and just like this sucks like i don't
these things were kind of lame before
now i'm not even flying anymore what do
i need what do i need delta points
i got i was hyped when uh american
airlines decided
to uh they like extended the um
what you know whatever the status that
you had gotten maybe extended an extra
year and i'll say oh this is awesome you
know
this coveted thing will be uh over in a
couple of weeks and then uh
you know i'll basically have a whole
extra year and then i was like wait a
second
i'm not flying anywhere that's right so
it's not gonna end up mattering
uh second question is uh there are
certain states that
you guys are not available in um and i
get
berated on the internet my dms are full
of people saying when
whatever state what's kind of the update
there in terms of
how many states are you guys in and then
what's the timeline look like to get
the rest of them yeah so we have some of
our products available in every state
the probably number one thing that uh
that uh people you know talk about and
that i wish we could change but we we
actually don't have
uh any near-term plans that look like
this will change is that you're not able
to earn interest on
your crypto if you are in new york so
currently in the state of new york
you're the only product you're able to
access is our loan product
um but every other state in the u.s you
can earn interest on your crypto
um and then there's about
35 out of the 50 states where you can
wire money
uh in and out of our platform um
that's an area where we're actively
adding more states
our regulatory construct is that we have
an msp
registration at the federal level money
services business then we have lending
licenses and money transmission licenses
at the state level
that second state level license the
money transmission
transmission license is what we're in
the process of getting in more states
now
so um as we get those licenses
like uh you know i know jason williams
from your team was really pumped because
we got our north carolina money
transmission license a month or two ago
and so
people in north carolina are able to
wire in and out
we you know open up that functionality
to folks in the state so if you're
curious
what you can do in your state if you go
to blockfy.com rates
and you scroll down on the page uh it'll
talk about
you know whether you can get loans or an
interest trade and move money in and out
of your bank account
uh or or only a subset of those things
mr going parabolic himself is uh
he loves blackfy as everyone knows um
last thing for you uh and you don't know
that i'm asking this
um the interest that you have had
in block five from investors has uh been
unlike pretty much anything else i've
ever seen
um the data speaks for itself you
florey the rest of the team's execution
speaks for itself
um you have had the fortune on numbers
numerous times now on these investment
rounds where
insiders have preempted the rounds and
kind of
been able to um you know give you a vote
of confidence
what's your reaction when you get these
term sheets right when it's kind of just
like
you're doing everything that you want uh
and then you're getting a term sheet
without having to kind of go out and go
through a whole fundraising process that
most founders have to go through um
yeah i mean you know to be completely
fair we we
usually go through a bit of a
fundraising
process because we don't want to um
you know get a term sheet from an
insider and not do a little bit of a
of a market check but my reaction is
always
uh you know kind of one part excitement
and
one part uh you know uh pinching myself
at
you know how great this is but but that
feeling that feeling only lasts for so
long because because then what happens
is
um you know you sign the term sheet you
figure out the allocations for the round
uh you close it and work doesn't stop
while you're going through those steps
and then
once you get on the other side of it
it's kind of like you can never really
i don't i don't have a good uh ability
to
just be like all right we're good let's
all you know like take a few weeks off
and chill it's like no
we're on to the next thing um you know
so you know
you were there we had a board meeting uh
last week
and we're not talking about okay guys
what do we need to do to close and
announce the series c it's like we're
talking about
where we need to be by the end of this
year and where we're going to be next
year
and you you come out of that meeting and
you're like holy [ __ ] we have a lot of
work to do
so let's get to it um but it's great man
look we're
uh we're thrilled to be where we are
we're very fortunate
uh to have a business that's able to
keep growing and have
you know clients who continue to uh you
know see value in the products and
services that we offer and so
uh we're just gonna keep going uh
what do you want this to become right
when you look
20 years from now 10 years from now what
does this
kind of evolve into or grow into uh
it'll be interesting to see i've always
said um
you know the things that i want uh are
a good outcome from a capitalist
perspective for
uh you know the people who work at the
company and
uh you know everybody who works at
blockchain has uh
a level of you know equity ownership in
the business and our investors who
you know give give us money and if those
two people make money i'm sure i'll i'll
do just fine
um so number one objective is let's have
a good outcome
uh number two objective is let's have
fun in the process of doing that
and not you know create an environment
where we don't
enjoy doing the stuff that we're doing
and working with the people that we're
working with to get it done
and then lastly if possible let's let's
change the world for the better a little
bit and so i think what that last piece
for blockbuy looks like
is a more globally accessible
uh financial services platform
that creates uh
you know better pricing for the same
types of things people already do
with the traditional system whether
that's how much interest you earn
or how much it costs to you know move
money around
um and that creates uh greater
accessibility like
one of the coolest things about crypto
one of the things that drew me into it
initially is like okay it's like the
internet like you
you can connect to the internet you can
access the cryptocurrency space and
there's a lot of uh
you know there's a lot of bad stuff that
goes on in the world when it comes to um
how governments operate and and what
they do with the money supply
and we're very fortunate in america here
to have the world reserve currency and
a lot of places don't have that benefit
and i think that
the cryptocurrency space in general and
as a subset of that our platform
can be used to kind of uh better the
financial services outlook for
global society and that's like insane
right like i mean
that's the that's the top of the you
know potential
dream that we have with block five
you're sitting in a
rocking chair 40 years from now and
you're like remember that time we built
a you know
globally accessible bank that was just
like better than anything else that
existed before it i mean that that
that would be pretty cool so we'll see
how far we get
you're well on your way there my friend
um if anyone wants to
sign up they can obviously go to
blockfy.com
if you go to slash pump i actually don't
remember what you get but you get
discounts treats whatever it is uh so go
do that
um what's kind of your your closing
thoughts for uh for people who are
evaluating block fi in terms of becoming
a potential user
um what would you say to them uh we've
got
uh you know probably in my biased
opinion
the best client service team in crypto
we might be the only place where there's
a phone number at the bottom of our
website you can call and talk to these
folks
uh you know any any time during business
hours
uh you can email them you can tweet at
us so
try it out talk to the team ask us
questions give us feedback
we would you know we'd love to uh engage
with you and
uh potentially work with you as a client
i think we should
before the end of this show like pomp
you led this investment round
and and i know you're interviewing me
but like but why don't you
tell people why uh you decided to be the
insider who
you know let a series see in the in the
block with all the information and
um you know stuff that you do at morgan
creek
yeah i thought i was going to get away
with not having to talk to him at all
look
um i think that there's two core things
that
uh you know in this specific situation
made this like a no-brainer from our
standpoint so
first of all is uh my opinion
or anybody else's opinion matters when
you just look at the data right and the
data is
very very compelling that not only does
the company have product market fit
uh but it's also scaling uh and those
products have a lot of scalability left
in them right so they're not products
that are kind of
um hey we're gonna cap out at a certain
number of users these are things that
you can make a strong argument are just
starting and you can see a very long
runway
to use it now the benefit of that is
there's a bunch of
data points in the legacy world that we
can kind of look at and see
know how did those wealth management
services or those types of financial
services businesses
start products scale products and kind
of what were those outcomes
and so i think kind of looking at the
data today with that as the backdrop
very compelling the second thing is um
you know i am not shy about my
conviction in terms of
kind of a future digital world right and
so if you look at the services that
the company provides these are essential
to
convincing people to switch to the
alternative system
right and you just can't do that as much
as we would like to think you can
you can't do that without debt uh debt
products right you can't do that without
some sort of yield
product you can't do that without um you
know credit card type products you can't
do that without
average actually having a conversion
point back and forth between fiat and
digital currencies like with an exchange
and so i think that you just know that
this infrastructure's got to get built
and and if you go back to kind of that
example i used where you compare like
the robin hood or a brokerage type
business versus a
deposit and payment type business i'm a
very big believer that the deposit
deposit and payment business is a uh a
model that can
scale really well uh can be highly
profitable
uh but it also can align value with the
user
right the users of those products end up
getting just as much value if not more
than the company gets right so you don't
get in a world where like the company's
taking all the value and
the user basically has no other options
they're locked into a product
and so when you look at that um i think
a lot of people
uh in crypto the thought process is
still
um as every vertical uh when people
start these businesses
it's like how do i build a company to
sell it or how do i get to
100 million exit or like if i reach
really really far like imagine if i
could build a billion dollar business
right and those are all great outcomes a
lot of times they can be very
profitable for founders employees
investors like
there's nothing wrong with that every
once in a while though
i think a company comes along that has
the potential to do something much
greater than that
right and um you know when i say much
greater
it's not only impact in the world but
it's from a market cap standpoint
and kind of what they can actually build
and i think that uh
it's rare to one have a business
that is set up in a way and built in a
way that can do it
to to have a founding team that has a
desire to go do that on an ambition
and then three is be able to access the
capital
and the investors that support that
vision right and so i think that you
guys have done a great job kind of
getting those three things
um aligned and so to your point like
you know you're raising a round that
most people would like literally be
celebrating and kind of doing all this
stuff and and
it doesn't mean that you guys aren't
happy about it or excited but
in the last board meeting i mean i don't
even think it was brought up one time in
terms of like the operation like yeah we
did that like it's gonna happen
right i mean it literally is like how do
we go from where we are now to
10x100 you know i mean like like let's
go and and it's more of
this money now allows you to slam on the
gas pedal even more
kind of double triple down on what's
working so i think that it's a lot of
little things um and you know for those
that don't know
uh stories um zach and i were talking
one day he was telling me some of the
data
and it was a conversation of just like
okay you guys are going to
go out and raise more capital like i
want to buy every share i possibly can
in this company
right like like literally zach if you'll
sell me all of your shares i'll buy all
of those too right like
like literally whatever we can do here
like this is a no-brainer deal
from a structure and a data standpoint
and i think that the the um
the really great position you found
yourself in is
we're not the only ones who believe that
like i think almost every investor at
the table
thinks that as well right and so you so
you get in a situation where
both insiders and outsiders all see uh
the value in the business
and now it just comes down to okay
capital is not gonna be a limitating
factor
zach flory the rest of the block fight
team it's just can you guys execute
right and i love when we just
compartmentalize the risk to
it's just an execution risk problem now
right
you know it's going to be really fun too
if uh
if it happens which i know both you and
i uh
you know very much believe it will
happen is
you know we launched we raised our seed
round in december of 2017.
we launched our first product in january
of 2018. we've been operating
you know below all-time highs for
bitcoin and you know
some version of a bear market slash
you know range-bound market
i'm like incredibly confident that
bitcoin's gonna hit new all-time highs
sometime in the next
you know six to 18 months that's gonna
be
so fun to like like have all this stuff
you know here and ready and built uh
and then uh you know have that available
to folks in a scenario where
you know all the mainstream press is
paying attention again because bitcoin
hit a new all-time high and they thought
it was dead i mean it's gonna be filed
well and and i think also it it um is
gonna be a thing where
before people were making a binary
decision do i buy bitcoin or not
right because that's basically what you
could do and again you know i'm
one of the biggest proponents of uh of
this stuff so
um i think that that was a good answer
now
when we go into this uh bull market
again i think what people are going to
be able to say is wait a second i can
buy the asset i can earn interest on the
asset i can use this collateral right
like there's things that i can do
uh i could have my airline points and
get bitcoin instead
of course and so it's just the the
infrastructure right and blockbuster's
been a big piece of that it's not block
finally like there's companies all
across the industry that have built a
ton of infrastructure
um that i think would just be more
compelling to people and so it'll be a
lot of fun to kind of watch it play
all right man always fun coming on the
show thanks for having me
you got it blockfit.com zach is a
uh going to continue going so we'll do
this again in the future
see you man